the 1818 novel was revolutionary in its
depiction of science and religion and
served as a pioneer text in the sci-fi
genre Mary Shelley's Frankenstein on the
surface it's a novel about a scary
monster but her sympathetic description
of a soulful creature makes us rethink
who we label as the monster I'm dr.
Emily zarqa and this is monstrum
remember this is not Frankenstein this
is although Shelley's character was not
a doctor of any kind he never actually
even finished his university studies
crazy I've decided to refer to him as
dr. Frankenstein as he was first called
in the 1931 movie to emphasize the
distinction between him and his creation
dr. Frankenstein was the scientist who
created the nameless creature for his
Karloff's depiction of a tall shambling
mute man with bolt sticking out of his
neck has become the classic image of the
monster Shelley's original description
is actually much more macabre
Shelley writes quote his yellow skin
scarcely covered the work of muscles and
arteries beneath his hair was of a
lustrous black and flowing his teeth of
a pearly whiteness his watery eyes his
shriveled complexion and straight black
lips Shelley's dr. Frankenstein
assembled his creature from materials
found in Charnel houses the vaults were
corpses were kept but he also took bits
from the slaughterhouse
so yes her creature is made of both
human and animal parts but here's the
thing
the creature definitely looks scary but
just because something looks scary that
doesn't mean it is Shelley's original
creation is a highly intelligent
vegetarian who hates the idea of harming
another living creature at the beginning
of the novel he wants nothing more than
to be accepted in love
by another being ironically it's the
monstrous treatment he receives from
humans that drives him to kill dr.
Frankenstein abandons the creature at
the moment of his animation Lenny what
basically amounts to a newborn wander
into the darkness alone to fend for
himself
the tension between Frankenstein and the
creature represents the struggle between
peri and child self and other love and
hate science and morality abandonment
and acceptance it's a warning
to treat all living things with respect
or else 200 year-old spoiler alert
Shelley's novel ends with Frankenstein
and his entire family dead and the
creature himself presumably committed
suicide what led Mary Shelley to explore
these dark and tragic themes that's
complicated Mary's life was plagued by
death her own mother died from delivery
complications only a few days after
giving birth Shelley would mourn the
woman she never knew for the rest of her
life
Shelley's first child with her married
lover Percy died shortly after birth in
1815 the following year was known as the
year without a summer
due to the lingering effects of the
eruption of Mount Tambora stuck indoors
Shelley and her friends entered into a
dare depend the most terrifying story
they could imagine Shelley's story came
to her in a nightmare in 1818 she
finished Frankenstein and was finally
able to get married but only because
Percy's pregnant wife committed suicide
Mary's second child Clara also died that
year and their third child William
followed Clara to the grave in 1819 then
just four years later in 1822 Percy's
drowned body washed ashore all that
death and grief may be why when editing
Frankenstein for an 1831 edition Shelley
made dr. Frankenstein's decision to form
the creature a matter of fate this
change makes the creature more of a
monster as his violence and desire to
destroy Frankenstein becomes his
shelli's original text and all those
that follow in at shadow makes us ask
who is the real monster in this story we
are constantly updating the Frankenstein
myth and the themes of life loss and
monstrosity Shelley wove into the
original text as a way to explore our
definitions of humanity interpretations
like ex machina explore the intimate and
complicated relationship between the
creator and the created and ask the
audience to consider if robotic
consciousness constitutes life you are
dead center of the greatest scientific
event in the history of man if you've
created a conscious machine it's not the
history of man that's the history of
gods the film splice looks at how
engineering human and animal DNA to
design an entirely new life-form can
result in dangerous unforeseen
complications even if the creator
shelters educates and loves their
creation do you think they could really
look at this face and see anything less
than a miracle
Frankenweenie retells the Frankenstein
story as a young boy's decision to
resurrect his dead dog emphasizing the
devastation and desperation that comes
from loss
[Music]
the 2017 comic series Victor Laval's
destroyer update Shelley's story for the
current moment adding important
conversations about race gender
immigration police brutality social
injustice and the proliferation of
violence in the modern world
all of these interpretations show
sympathy for both the creatures and
their tragically flawed creators despite
all the destruction that comes from
scientific experimentation in these
adaptations
I don't believe Shelley intended her
original story to scare readers into
believing all Sciences evil or monstrous
I do think she warns us to consider the
repercussions of technological and
scientific advancement just because we
can doesn't mean we should Shelley's
novel caused us to be accountable for
what we create and what might be
destroyed in the process check out
soundfield the new music education show
from PBS Digital Studios from Bach to
Beyonce they break down our favorite
songs and styles looking at things like
theory history and culture it's hosted
by two amazing musicians Nara and LA who
even collaborate to create an original
song for every episode check it out in
the link below and tell them dr. Z sent
you but usually the issue is I closed
both my like the I can't do this on des
it's my movement I need a hair Wrangler
[Music]